Hey youtubers it's Charlie and today I wanted
to dedicate a video to Doctor Who Companions,
I already did some of my old favorites last
year so this time I wanted to talk about the
top 10 people I want to see become new companions.
We also have some more info on the actual
date of the Series 8 premiere so I'll start
off with that.
Because really the biggest thing we want to
know is when we get to start watching episodes
again.
If you're finding me for the first time I'm
going to be doing weekly Doctor Who bonus
videos up to the series 8 premiere.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Once episodes start I'll be doing 3 videos
a week for episodes just like I do for game
of thrones right now.
I'll even be doing a weekly giveaway.
Important stuff first, there's a Doctor Who
World tour starting on August 7th in the UK
and ending August 19th in Brazil.
The BBC announced Peter Capaldi and people
from the show will be promoting the series
in a bunch of different cities in anticipation
of the series 8 premiere.
That language is very important, in "Anticipation"
So what does that mean?
Essentially Capaldi will be traveling around
doing press and then after the tour is over
they'll have the worldwide premiere.
August 19th is on a Tuesday, so tentatively
plan for the Series 8 premiere to be on Saturday
August 23rd.
It's totally possible they could have the
premiere in the middle of the tour or even
at the start of the tour.
But because the BBC used the language "in
anticipation of", I think it implies they're
trying to build excitement before the premiere,
not after it.
I'll post a link in the description for all
the tour dates in case they're coming to your
city and you want to try and go.
They're visiting Seven cities total.
Now let's talk about some new companions.
The fun thing is that there can be a lot of
them, unless it's the 50th Anniversary or
The Doctor is having vanity issues.
There can only be one of him in any given
episode.
But companions can come and go all the time.
So here are the top 10 new companions I'd
like to see in a future series.
They've almost finished series 8 filming,
so none of these people would make it this
year.
Number 10 - John Bradley from Game of Thrones
Samwell on Doctor Who would be so much fun.
There's a lot of historical figures he could
play like young Winston Churchill, but as
a companion I'd really like to see him play
a grown up version of Stormageddon.
He's already playing a good analog for Craig
on Game of Thrones.
Plus he would get to be part of a meta sci
fi mashup with some other Game Of Thrones
actors on my list.
That's one of the things I love about british
series and series that film in Europe.
You see a lot of the same actors bounce around.
So a lot of people who have worked together
on Doctor Who have worked together on a lot
of other series too.
Number 9 - Antonia Thomas from Misfits
So she's acutally just been cast in Series
2 of The Musketeers which also stars Peter
Capaldi, he's going to have to leave the show
because of Doctor Who commitments, but see
what I mean about actors working together
on different series.
It's really her character on Misfits, if you
never saw it.
A bunch of juvenile deliquents get caught
in a storm and get super powers.
Hers was sexual attraction.
She had River Song level pheromones, so she
would be an amazing as a companion on Doctor
Who that may or may not be the daughter or
River Song.
I know Jenny is supposed to be the Doctor's
Daughter, but it's just funny to think of
the Doctor having an alternate universe version
of a daughter that takes after River more.
Also fun fact, another Game of Thrones actor
who starred on Misfits with Antonia was Ewan
Rheon who plays Ramsay Snow, now Ramsay Bolton.
He'd make a good Doctor Who villain.
Number 8 - Freya Mevor from Skins
On Skins she went from being like a mean girl
queen bee to a mother and a caregiver.
You could say that all of the Doctor's female
companions end up taking care of him at some
point so I'd really like to see her get something
of a modified Donna Noble arc where she goes
from meltdown celebutant to hero.
Like remember between series 6 and series
7 when they did that weird plot with Amy becoming
a super celebrity and her marriage with Rory
falling apart.
I wasn't a huge fan of that, but thematically
it fits.
Freya as the celebrity getting swept up in
the Doctor's life.
Fun Fact, Frey starred on Skins with two other
Game of Thrones actors Hannah Murray and Joe
Dempsie who play Gilly and Gendry.
Number 7 - Ruth Wilson from Luther
She's a little bit older than some of the
twenty something's Doctor Who usually casts
as Companions, but I wanted to include a few
fantasy picks for actors who are just amazing.
On Luther her Alice character is incredibly
sinister.
Like River Song when she was still the insane
version of Melody Pond.
She'd even make a fantastic Lady Time Lord.
I think given the darker more serious tone
of Peter Capaldi's Doctor, she'd be a good
foil.
You don't always have to have silly companions,
so she's my choice for a devilish grin companion.
Not an evil companion, just one that delights
in a little chaos.
She's also one of the few actresses on my
list that looks amazing as a ginger and Paul
McGann was a recurring guest star on Luther.
Number 6 - Hannah Murray from Game of Thones
I really just want to see Gilly become a Doctor
Who companion is what I'm saying.
Like Samwell finds her a new place to hide
that just ends up being a police box conveniently
parked in the library of Castle Black.
She was also on Skins with Joe Dempsie.
Her character Cassie Ainsworth was a total
mess of a human being with all kinds of problems
with addiction and eating disorders.
The Doctor is a healer, I'd really like to
see Hannah do a version of Cassie that becomes
empowered as a result of her adventures in
the TARDIS.
Not empowered like Bad Wolf empowered.
But you get the idea.
Number 5 - Laura Donnelly from Merlin
On that show she played the character who
became the Lady of The Lake.
She was a tragic character who was cursed
and fell in love with Merlin but eventually
ascended to become this hugely important character.
Very similar to Bad Wolf Rose Tyler.
I don't want to see another romantic companion
so soon after River Song, but I do like the
idea of the ticking clock.
They kind of did it with Clara and the Impossible
girl plot.
But I'd like to see Laura play a companion
that the Doctor always knows will die soon.
Like a reverse version of the Lake Silencio
plot in series 6, where the doctor always
has to die at a fixed point.
So using time travel they just avoid that
moment in time for a whole series.
Fun Fact: Laura starred on Merlin with Eve
Myles of Torchwood, Joe Dempsie of Game of
Thrones and John Hurt the 8.5 Doctor or 9th
Doctor, depending on how you look at it.
Number 4 - Rose Leslie
I don't want to post any Game of Thrones spoilers
about Ygritte here, but I'm such a fan of
the previous ginger companion that I really
want Rose Leslie to be Ygritte to the Doctor's
Jon Snow.
Not in a romantic way, just a companion that
isn't going to take any of the Doctor's crap.
All of my favorite companions were always
smarter and more helpful than the Doctor most
of the time.
Yes, the Doctor always comes through in the
end.
But day to day, it's the Companion that usually
ends up seeming like the smart one.
Rose Leslie would make an amazing young companion
who can order the Doctor around without seeming
too bossy.
Number 3 - Karla Chrome misfits
On that show her superpower was seeing through
people's bullshit, like when they were lying.
I'd really like to see how that ability would
work when the first rule is "The Doctor Always
Lies".
Just imagine Capaldi saying random things
and her just going, "Bullshit" very softly
in the background.
Even just whispering it under her breath.
Number 2 - Richard Ayoade
He was actually rumored for the role of The
Doctor for a long time but I'm kind of glad
they didn't pick him just because Matt Smith's
thing was being the sillier version of the
Doctor and Ayoade is an excellent comedian.
But a comedy driven Doctor for 6 or 8 years
in a row is just too much of the same.
That's why I really want to see him as a companion.
Just a really dry funny scientist or totally
unremarkable person who can punch up Capaldi's
scenes if they get too dry.
That's the thing I really love about British
humor.
Sometimes it can be so subtle you don't realize
it's a joke.
Most of the time I appreciate that kind of
humor more than the really obvious jokes you
see in stuff like 22 Jump Street.
There's at least one dick joke every five
minutes in that movie.
And I laughed a lot.
But I think Ayoade's dry humor would be so
much more appropriate for Doctor Who.
Why else would they have considered him for
the Doctor if he wasn't perfect for the series?
Number 1 - Kate McGrath from Merlin
She plays Morgana on Merlin and I think she
would make an amazing companion.
She would be my dream casting.
Like a companion who could run circles around
the Doctor.
I feel like the best companions should also
be people who would make amazing time lords.
And in order to do that you have to be powerful
and really quick.
Like Stephen Colbert quick, mentally that
is.
Just like a machine gun of thoughts.
I know a lot of you Game of Thrones fans would
like to see her play Lyanna Stark, but there's
no reason she couldn't do both.
There are like 3 Game of Thrones actors on
my list.
One of the benefits of british series running
shorter than American series is that it leaves
more time for the actors to do other shows.
So Morgana Pendragon gets my number 1 vote
for a future companion.
Now it's your turn though, which actor or
actress would you like to see as a companion?
Bonus points for crossing the fandom streams.
Since I'm posting this kind of late I'm not
going to have time to do an Orphan Black video
tonight.
So I'll just be doing some tumblr gifs and
writing my thoughts down there.
You're also welcome to ask me questions about
that in these comments.
My next Doctor Who video will post next Saturday,
I haven't quite decided what it's going to
be but feel free to leave me suggestions.
Right now click here to get ready for the
big Game of Thrones finale this weekend and
click here to learn more about the series
8 episodes.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!